it's time now for Friday Follies is this
[Music]
is this one of the signs of the
Apocalypse well you know something
Strange's up when they start quoting the
Bible on MSNBC here to explain it to us
and so much more in tonight's Friday
Follies is New York Times bestselling
author Fox News contributor Raymond
Arroyo who joins us from New Orleans
Raymond apparently there's an explosion
of men also diving into plastic surgery
let's hope that's not a Father's Day
trend what's up right oh yeah we're
gonna get into all of that I got to
start with this this Bible mania that's
overtaking the network's Laura look
earlier this week the Southern Baptist
Convention and the Catholic Bishops
chastised the Trump administration for
their immigration policies well that
provoked Jeff Sessions our Attorney
General he took the religious bait and
started quoting scripture saying st.
Paul tells us you have to obey the law
well now wonder of wonders Ali Velshi
today is on MSNBC he looked like Pat
Robertson's understudy look we actually
did dig through the Bible to find
passengers that lent themselves to the
current border practice of separating
migrant children from their parents and
I want to begin with Matthew chapter 19
verse 14 but jesus said suffer little
children and forbid them not to come
unto me laura's forbidding children from
going to Jesus
this is conflating the scripture and
turning it into a public policy
pronouncement that it was never intended
to be uh how long did the Bible read and
go on on MSNBC I'm glad they I'm glad to
have the Bible over there that's a
positive thing no no no this went on and
on Ali looks like a theologian look uh
not finished yet let's go to Isaiah
chapter 10 woe unto them that decree
unrighteousness decrees and that right
grievousness okay we got a point that
one's interesting Laura but that's an
Old Testament reading it is is Ollie
suggesting we should be a theocracy
where you follow God's commands and the
kings follow his orders I don't think so
look this policy of separating parents
had
been on the books for years they did it
during the Obama administration they did
it during the Bush administration now I
see clerics all over TV saying God
wouldn't want this there are a lot of
things God wouldn't want a Bible the
government manual let's go all the all
the Catholic churches that can take all
the eleven thousand kids they can clothe
them feed them set them to college all
the medical care because the tax payers
are out of dough they're sick of it
Raymond we have to get into the
explosion of men who are doing plastic
surgery okay I knew you'd want to go out
I haven't had any I love this segment I
love the sermon okay so what are the
most popular types of plastic surgery
for the you know the metrosexual men out
there with their skinny jeans well it's
a man person more it's risen it's risen
by 29 percent here at the top five and
I'm surprised by this actually the first
is nose reshaping then eyelid surgery
liposuction breast reduction was number
four breast reduction hair transplant
hair transplants were at the bottom I
thought they'd be at the top but breast
reductions apparently top it I don't
need any help they're just you know when
people say the word moobs is that what
they're talking about and mice allowed
to say that on TV so okay why not so
it's not an augmentation unless we're
talking about a gender transformation
it's a Reducto they are they're reducing
they're reducing the man boobage I have
to get to one other thing Kraft cheese
just started a contest for Father's Day
they auctioned off five sculptures of
dad they're calling it cheesy is great
now can you imagine doing a promotion
like this for Mother's Day
saying mom is cheesy I doubt it I hate
this diminishment of dad I saw another
thing fitting in a Planet Fitness put
out a calendar about
dad bods you know diminishing dads bods
this is a bad time to be kind of
wrapping dad's making him look like a
fool in it it's Father's Day we should
celebrate men and celebrate celebrate
Father's male role models all across
this country who act his father's
Raymond's Godfather him as a godfather
one of my kids so come on hey thank you
all three I brought my daughter tonight
all right I have a great weekend rain